if you've gone to a tech conference
literally any tech conference in the
last five years you would walk away with
the impression that the
connected easy to navigate clean and
green smart city is just around the
corner
the reality is that and the hype is that
many companies are working on products
and solutions to get there
take transportation for example
allegedly in the city of the future you
will be able to seamlessly plan your
journey from public transportation to
shared autonomous taxis and even
electric scooters
if you own a car it will be electric and
there will be charging stations
strategically placed throughout the city
so all you do is type your location into
your gps and it will automatically take
you to your location in the minimum
amount of time and any payment you need
for charging will be done automatically
in the background
now you might say wait a minute there
are companies that are doing this today
i can do this today but it's individual
companies and it's certainly not
ubiquitous across the across the city
but it doesn't just stop with
transportation
let's take health
in the future there will be air quality
monitors at every street corner and they
will be connected with your asthma
inhaler so that you know when it's safe
to go out or
there will be infrared cameras that are
measuring the temperature of citizens
anonymously and that will be connected
with your thermometer so that we can
detect future outbreaks and of course
you will also have your wearable device
that's connected to your
your bathroom scale and your smart
refrigerator so that nutritionists
doctors and other companies can come up
with new ways to keep you you know slim
and and trim as i am
so then of course there's shopping i
mean when you shop today you know you
purchase from different retailers and
you receive multiple shipments during
the course of the day now if you had an
app where you could set your preferences
and those shipments can be consolidated
and maybe you receive fewer shipments
during the week a little bit less
convenient but you get to reduce your
carbon footprint
so these are all great ideas and
solutions and products that companies
are working on
but they all share an underlying
requirement that could make that smart
city more of a distant dream than a
reality just around the corner
and that is the need for greater sharing
of data across companies individuals and
cities
and if there's one thing that we've
learned is that companies don't like to
share data they don't even like to share
our own data with us
so let alone data with competitors or
partners
and therein lies a dilemma
because if we want to have a chance at
really combating climate change
we need to
have our cities become as smart and as
connected as quickly as possible in as
many cities as possible
so we need to overcome this fear of data
sharing and and move towards
the smart city future
but why is it that companies fear
sharing data
well it's what i call foma not fomo the
fear of missing out on a great party or
other opportunity but foma the fear of
missing out on competitive advantage
data is a source of competitive
advantage so why would companies want to
give it up
in our research over the last few years
we've been looking at many different
solutions that would improve the citizen
experience and as well sustainability
solutions for cities and what we found
is that 85
of those solutions require much more
data sharing across companies
individuals and cities
so the question really comes how do we
motivate companies to share more of
their data
we need to actually overcome this fear
quickly if we want to make meaningful
progress on climate change
well as we talked to a number of
companies that were building platforms
and ecosystems in different verticals
like logistics transportation smart
buildings smart cities
we asked about what it would take to
drive greater data sharing across these
different solutions and what we heard
were the usual concerns data sharing is
costly it's complicated and companies
were concerned about unintended
disclosures that could risk their brand
however there was one exception and this
i think is promising
companies were more willing to share
their data
if it could serve a broader common
purpose beyond commercial motivations
and in particular
they're more willing to share their data
beyond their own four walls if that data
sharing could help fight climate change
let's take for example a few car
companies that actually are fierce
competitors and they got together and
started to share detailed mapping data
so they could develop better solutions
for routing trucks so they spent less
time idling and and also could route
trucks in a city based on prevailing
wind patterns to reduce smog these are
pretty cool solutions that companies are
working on
but the real question is if this common
purpose of fighting climate change can
help leaders overcome their data sharing
foma how do we get them to actually do
it
well in our work we found that it takes
three actions to jump start a virtuous
cycle of data sharing and innovation
first
companies need to look for new
unexpected sources of data
second they need to develop new
sustainability solutions quickly
and third they need to act together for
change
let's take
finding new unexpected partners for data
well what i mean by that is looking well
beyond the four walls of a company for
sources of data that can be combined
with a company's own
to analyze and develop new
sustainability solutions but let me give
a specific example
let's take farming
farming historically has been more art
and science you've had farmers that make
decisions on when to plant what
fertilizer to apply
when to irrigate etc based on their own
personal experience and knowledge of the
farm
do you remember star trek
and when
spock could scan the surface of a planet
to know what the habitat was we're using
the sensors from the enterprise and they
could tell whether the planet could
support human life
well i know i'm dating myself and i'm a
bit of a geek but but but that that
science fiction
is becoming a reality today you have
data from satellites from drones from
centers on the field from connected
farming equipment that is collecting
data all of that can be combined so that
farmers can make better real-time
decisions how to improve their overall
crop yield reduce the amount of
fertilizer and other chemicals they need
and also conserve scarce resources like
water
so they can improve their income lower
their costs and now they can even start
generating new
income sources by planting carbon
absorbing crops and and getting paid for
that so
really quite fascinating what's
happening in agriculture
next comes
innovating quickly new sustainability
solutions
what i'm talking about is not your
typical long product roadmap but we need
to have companies hire data scientists
that can analyze all these different
data sources
and in new agile ways bring new products
and services to market we need to use
data and digital quickly to fight
climate change
finally acting together now let me come
back to the smart city example
if we had transportation companies and
utilities and buildings share data with
the city then the city could make better
decisions on
investing in renewable energy projects
that could mean that you lower your
energy bill and also
reduce your carbon footprint
or that transportation data can be used
to decide where charging stations are
needed so that we can accelerate the
speed of adoption of electric vehicles
and that means maybe you spend less time
in traffic but also your air is cleaner
so to really make progress on more
sustainable
energy we need to have data sharing
across buildings transportation and
utilities
all of this data sharing needs to come
together for a brighter future
now
you also have a critical role to play of
course we individually need to be in
control of our own data
imagine you have an app that allows you
to set preferences so that data from
your car from your utilities from your
shopping patterns can be shared and you
can make decisions about your own carbon
footprint in a very easy way so you can
run what-if scenarios what if i purchase
an electric car what if i take the train
from boston to new york versus fly or if
what if i change my shopping patterns so
i shop more locally how much will that
impact my overall carbon footprint would
you be willing to share more data to
have more sustainable climate and to
make those climate-friendly decisions
well
i for one i'm pretty excited about this
future a future where greater data
sharing can really help us jointly
combat climate change
what we need is for company leaders to
move away from foma
and back to good old-fashioned fomo
the future is bright if all that data
can be shared and i don't think we
really want to miss out thank you
[Applause]